do you guys look at like I'm thinking of
the guys from Oasis those two brothers
they can't [ __ ] get the room either
do you look at them and go are they
ridiculous they should just get together
it's not I completely we toured with
them that must have been and we freaked
them out they couldn't believe how much
you guys fought when you guys would get
into physical fights there were rules
right you couldn't hit each other in the
face that was the one rule pretty much
would you kick him in the shin elbow in
the throat no face look Howard you know
when you have these kind of good looks I
want to [ __ ] it up another thing we had
to take our music seriously cuz we just
didn't want to coast on the good looks
you know and you can't break your
brothers fingers because he's got to
play the guitar and you can't kick you
in the throat cuz you got to sing but we
really wanted to hurt each other so
you're saying when you were on tour with
Oasis they freaked out Oh your fights
were so loud and vicious that they were
like geez
we gotta be we got a really big fight
and at Merriweather Post Oh Chris was
late to soundcheck and everyone was
freaking out and so he and I got into
and our tour manager walked outside and
Liam and Noah were outside the door
going listen to that boy they need help
I mean like Don and Phil Everly they
didn't like each other okay and Dave
Davies they had issues legendary but
brothers but I kind of get it I mean
it's just the what you know brothers
it's hard in families to get along
really I wouldn't change anything in
really yeah rich you would you wouldn't
want to go through that again with the
angst teaches you you know a lot of
times the it's the harder things in life
that really are the ones that have the
lessons